so flex is the art of switching between
leadership styles in order to better
effectively communicate with people who
are different from you so different from
you generationally culturally and across
the gender divide it's about stretching
your leadership style and not
fundamentally changing who you are and
about adapting to the people across from
you so that you can get the best results
well the workforce is changing and has
been changing for a number of years I
believe multicultural workers make up
36% of the population women make up
nearly half of the workforce and I think
make up something like 70% of buying
decisions and certainly Millennials are
increasingly a bigger part of the
workforce as well and so there are so
many demographic changes that are
impacting our workforce I don't know if
managers are always certain about how to
work with this new workforce how to
better engage and motivate these new
workers that are entering to the
workforce in addition to that there's
there's a cost of not flexing so for
example I think the Gallup study last
year said something about four hundred
fifty to fifty five hundred fifty
billion dollars of loss due to
disengaged employees so you might have
employees that you've hired into the
organization that maybe have one foot
out the door that really don't feel
motivated and engaged and don't feel
like the organization is really speaking
to them so for this and many reasons I
think there's such a business case and
an opportunity for an organization to to
create a value proposition for their
employees if they can get this right the
power gap is a pretty critical element
in the I art of flexing the power gap is
the amount of social distance that
exists between yourself and people who
are in positions of authority and if
you're the manager people things that
exist between yourself and your team
members and so you can have a small
power gap or a large power gap if you
have a small power gap it's more of an
egalitarian relationship where even as a
manager you you see yourself as more of
a coach or a guide and you have a very
informal relationship with your
colleagues if you have a high power gap
and you're the employee you see your
leader as maybe more of an authority
figure and there's a huge gap between
yourself and that corner office and so
the way that we see the power gap play
out in the workplace is pretty important
and we think as we think about the art
of flexing understanding the dynamics
the power gap particularly as it relates
to generational and cultural differences
can play a big part in your
effectiveness so as you work across
these differences your goal then is to
be a fluent leader and a fluent leader
is someone who can effectively manage
those differences in the workplace to
get the best business results one of the
traits of the fluent leader we found and
there's many traits but one of the
things that we want to focus on today is
innovation and ability to really see
outside the box and bring out the voices
of people who are on your teams who have
different perspectives and so I think of
one example in Douglas Conant who was a
former CEO of Campbell's Soup Company he
spent some time as a CEO really looking
at how do we increase customer
engagement he was hired at a time where
some of those numbers were slipping and
he really want to look at what were some
of the voices that we really can connect
to that haven't been heard to before and
so he they spent a few years really
looking at the voice of the women
customer how do we make decisions about
our product lines and service lines that
can appropriately reflect what they're
looking for and he worked with Denise
Morrison who is now actually the CEO of
the company to come up with some ideas
and from those conversations the healthy
request line was born and so when I
think about his example I think about
how he bridged the power gap right to
flex his style to ask the opinions of
people who maybe who are always there
but perhaps their voices weren't heard
in the loudest form and I love the fact
that he incorporated those voices into
the day-to-day business of how he around
the company
you